bonjour à tous ses amis avec fabien on
va vous parler quelques instants
d'amitié et de citer on va vous parler
de citer démocrate on va être bref parce
que le programme de travail de notre
université de rentrée cette année est
chargé et on est déjà un petit peu en
retard mais avant ça je voulais adresser
quelques remerciements merci d'abord à
toi françois merci de nous avoir
rassemblé une année encore sous le
soleil breton et on voit d'ici sous les
masques le sourire des grands jours le
sourire des retrouvailles le sourire du
plaisir de partager ensemble avec
évidemment une pensée toute particulière
pour pour marié merci à tous les
intervenants
merci à tous les intervenants à nos
ministres à nos parlementaires élus
locaux responsables de fédérations qui
vont animer nos débats dans les
plénières dans les ateliers de li fait
du
d'université 133 tout au long du week
end merci à vous qui avait traversé
terre et mer pour rejoindre ce site
auquel nous sommes tous attachés et puis
un immense merci évidemment à l'équipe
commando qui comme vous le savez travail
al'approche de guidel jour et nuit pour
pouvoir vous accueillir dans de bonnes
conditions et en particulier cette année
où il a fallu adapter un certain nombre
de choses au contexte sanitaire on peut
les applaudir très fort
je voulais les cités un par un mais le
temps nous manque donc peut-être
aurons-nous le temps de le faire un peu
plus tard dans le week-end alors
françois lors de notre congrès au mois
de décembre tu nous a dit avec avec
beaucoup de détermination que tu voulais
avancer vers notre fédération internet
ce que nous vous dévoilons aujourd'hui
c'est la première étape c'est la
première brique de cette fédération ces
cités démocrate cité démocrate qu'est ce
que c'est c'est une application qui est
téléchargeable sur le sur votre
téléphone et qui était téléchargeable
par part qu'il le souhaite en allant sur
apple store sur google store vous allez
recevoir le lien dans quelques instants
et fabien qui a été l'artisan va vous en
présenter le fonctionnement c'est un
nouvel espace de dialogue d'échangé de
partage un nouvel espace d'engagement
pourrez venir vous informer ou à venir
partager pourrait venir échanger des
messages avec des adhérents du mouvement
démocrate et toute la communauté qui
sera d'une certaine manière bien plus
large puisque ce que nous voulons c'est
adapter nos modes d'action aux nouvelles
formes d'engagement et donc en résumé si
tu es démocrate c'est un nouvel
instrument pour vous faire entendre et
pour vous engager pour un monde plus
juste c'est ça le slogan que françois a
voulu donner à cette application cité
démocrate c'est ça
[Musique]
et donc fabien va nous faire la
démonstration en direct bonjour à toutes
et tous merci beaucoup
c'est normalement le moment un peu
terrifiant la technique nous lâche et
non pas cette fois je vais donc ouvrir
l'application devant vous je vais pas
créer un compte pour aller plus vite je
vais utiliser directement le mien donc
vous voyez l'écran ici de mon téléphone
l'application se présente de cette
manière qu est ce que vous trouvez à
l'intérieur le petit clip on va pas le
visionner de nouveau des sondages on va
être amené dans cette application va
vous proposer toutes les semaines des
questions des sondages en fonction de
l'actualité vous en avez déjà un certain
nombre sur l'inflation sur l'allégement
du pass sanitaires ou bien encore la
réforme des retraites des quizz les
quizz ce sont des questionnaires un peu
plus longs notamment pour muscler sa
culture centre ici à des quizz
historique il ya un test de personnalité
vous verrez quel type de démocrates êtes
vous vous l'aurez compris on a essayé de
rendre les choses ludiques sympathique
pour éviter de retomber dans des
contenus habituel et puis enfin il ya
les actualités qui ne seront pas
toujours celle du site internet il y
aura beaucoup de vidéos que vous ne
trouverez que sur l'application est
effectivement oui mathieu ara si on may
cry on voit les sms sur l'écran donc tu
arrêtes s'il te plait merci beaucoup
et puis vous avez un profil personnel
sur lequel vous pouvez mettre votre
photo et surtout vous retrouvez la
communauté c'est à dire toutes les
personnes qui se sont inscrites et vous
pouvez les contacter directement vous
pouvez aussi filtrer par région vous
pouvez discuter entre vous dans une même
région on avait le problème éternel des
fichiers de pas pouvoir se contacter
entre nous on peut par le biais de
l'application sans divulguer vos données
personnelles se contacter jean noël
barrot vous a envoyé un message
effectivement et donc vous voyez qu'on a
déjà papoter avec un certain nombre de
personnes vraiment trop top cette
application voilà ce n'est comme l'a dit
jean noël qu'une première version on
veut que ce soit ludique donc vous avez
différents statuts vous gagnez des
points plus vous participez plus vous
gagnez des points on n'a pas encore trop
déterminer les lots mais on va on va y
réfléchir je suis sûr que vous avez
plein dit ici la prochaine étape les
prochaines étapes avant la fin de
l'année c'est le parrainage que vous
puissiez autour de vous envoyer cette
application ce lien par sms par mail
pour que des gens qui ne sont pas
nécessairement adhérents la télécharge
c'est donc le parrainage c'est aussi des
forums de discussion collective pour le
moment on pourra parler avec un mais à
l'avenir on va élargir tout ça voilà ce
qu'est la cité démocrates en quelques
mots merci à toute l'équipe merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lee